any sufficiently advanced technology
is indistinguishable from magic
have you ever been fired i have
it didn't feel excellent at the time but
in retrospect
it turned out to be one of the greatest
things that ever happened to me
in fact i probably wouldn't be here
talking to you right now if i hadn't
been fired long ago as a postdoc
working away at stanford university and
what i thought was my dream job
and it turned out to be somewhat of a
nightmare
but i'd never been fired before i had no
idea what to do next
and i really wish that i had a book like
your next five moves to kind of guide me
not to the final destination i think
that would be asking too much and it'll
be impossible for me to really
be able to glimpse what the future might
hold given the
traumatic circumstances of that recent
termination
however having it now and thinking about
the lessons that we can learn today from
our guest patrick bet david
on into the impossible thinking about
what you do
next it doesn't mean you have to know
where you're going to end up
oftentimes it's important as a pilot to
know your first few stops your first few
waypoints
along the way on your flight plan and if
you miss it
you're in for disaster so it doesn't
give you a guarantee of success of
getting to the destination
but without a flight plan you're
basically planning to fail
there's a saying that i quote often that
if you're off by just a quarter of a
degree
you can miss the moon you know the moon
is only about a half a degree wide
so you only have a tiny window a little
radius to make it to your destination
and so if you're off by this tiny half
of a half of a fingernail
held out at arm's length you'll miss the
moon and so
it's important to get the first few
moves down right
and then hopefully you'll get to the
destination intact
so today's guest is going to tell us
about that and tell us some other ideas
uh like about how he grew to a two and a
half million
subscriber following on youtube and how
he got to interview
some of the world's most fascinating
people including kobe bryant the late
great kobe bryant
so i hope you'll enjoy this episode uh
give me a uh
some comments some feedback i never know
how people enjoy this or not
my producer tells me to tell you to
please
hit the subscribe like notifications
button hit anything you can
just to keep the podcast going and
please leave a review on itunes if
you're listening to this
it's important for us in the algorithms
that control our destinies
as podcasters thanks again please enjoy
this very stimulating interview
with a fascinating character very
controversial character
uh and uh we'll see how that how that
plays out in today's interview
on the into the impossible podcast
patrick s my mom host brian
keating kosh almodin be into the
impossible podcast
welcome patrick it's good to be with you
i learned all of my farsi just to say
those words to you
that's all i get from you it took me it
took me a week to memorize that
that is impressive that is impressive i
think maybe you were maybe your your mom
is armenian and farsi and your dad is a
caucasian
because that's how my kids are my wife
is white from texas yeah and
his father is me so no i i get i get
confused for that i take it as a high
compliment
uh by my persian friends are are
spectacular anyway i got some help with
that because
uh i've been wanting to meet you and do
this interview and talk about your
phenomenal new book but i got a question
for you patrick
so you're you're a multi-millionaire
you're one of the most successful
youtubers in history
you left iran with basically the shirt
on your back
fled to germany had this exciting
upbringing that you opened the book up
with
you talk about it like it's a james bond
opening scene in the james bond movie
that's you why did you write this book
and
and let me ask you a question you get
fired today youtube
cancels you something happens on itunes
it's not uploading
what are your next five moves so that's
a great question so let me answer both
questions first
first of one first one is why did i
write this book so
why i wrote this book i wrote this book
because years ago i woke up in the
morning
and i never forget this i felt lost i
woke up in the morning
my phone had a text message from my
girlfriend saying you're spending way
too much time with the business
i think you love your business more than
you love me i think it's time we break
up so that's tech
six o'clock in the morning message from
a phone my mom's telling me how bad of a
son i am because
i haven't called her back and i don't
hear from you what happened to my little
son that wanted to talk to mom
so then i got the guilt feeling so my
heart's broken then i have guilt
then i check my email and my email says
that
the client i had just written up that
was going to pay me a good 15 000
commission he cancels because he's going
with the competitor
and then my number one sales rep also
resigned that all
happens within a five minute period in
the morning when i woke up
when i woke up i said i have no idea
what to do next so
in my mind at that time we were having a
lot of debates with different friends
where they were talking about what's the
key to success
some were saying the key to success is
you got to marry the right person you
got to go to school you got to
find god you got to work hard you got to
save money you got to take care of your
health
all of these different things so i said
i really want to know what is the key to
success
so when this has happened and the
dialogue about key to success and this
has happened in the morning in the first
five minutes girlfriend breakup mom is
disappointed
you know clients leaving me salespersons
leaving me i realize years later the
number one reason why some people
succeed is because they have a system
for how they process issues so
everything to me became in that moment
you could have ten different people
are gonna react to that problem in ten
different ways someone's gonna say
oh let me call my mom first and then let
me get together with my girlfriend spend
the whole day with her
and oh my gosh let me see so you the
sequence of how you handle that dictates
your success
and fast forward to today every single
time we make decisions with the company
we wanted to come out with systems
because everything for us here is about
standard operating procedures and it's
about leaving clues that i can teach you
how to solve problems how to solve
issues how to negotiate so one of the
reasons why i wrote
your next five moves is whether you're
getting married whether you want to have
kids
whether you're thinking about going from
single to being committed to somebody
whether you want to be a millionaire
whether you want to lose 40 pounds
everything comes down to your next five
moves and most people don't do them
right
they typically wanted to move 13 on move
number two and screws the whole thing up
so that's
first question right on on why i wrote
the book the second one is
if i lost everything today what would be
my next five moves one of the most
uh of comforting quotes i ever read
was there's two things they cannot take
away from you they can take everything
away from me they cannot take two things
one is what's in your stomach what you
ate
it's there the second thing is what you
fed here
so what you feed here and what you feed
here once you've fed your stomach it's
done it's yours
and what you feed your mind so you can
take everything away from me i can be
broke today i'd probably be depressed
for a month and i wouldn't want to see
anybody and maybe
i'll spend some time with jim jack and
you know all those guys and
you know want to go out there and hang
out with friends who just kind of want
to get over it and then eventually i'm
going gonna snap at it and say
here's what i'm gonna be doing and i'll
be back at it again with my next five
moves so
the strategies is what makes it more
evergreen to any industry it's not
specific to an industry
it's to any industry when you uh hear
the advice that i'm about to give you
uh i want to see how you react to it so
you often hear
um don't judge a book by its cover but
actually we all know people judge books
by their cover
i'm curious how did you come up with the
idea for both the cover
the artwork on the cover and the title
itself the title and the subtitle you
and your co-author i should mention
that's a great question so number one
originally i wanted to name it software
x
because in the book i talked about solve
for x but software x do
you know we talk about the fact that it
is a good topic but it's not a good
title for a book which i agree then we
agreed
uh originally when i was gonna uh
publish it with penguin instead of simon
schuster they like the deepest why what
is the deepest why because when you're
processing
issues you have to get to the deepest y
so we said deepest white then we said
let's solve you went from x to y by the
way you went from x to y
so then my uh my uh agent said let's go
solve for y
solve for y like w h y which i thought
was pretty creative that was one
thing and then i said your next 15 moves
they said 15 moves is way too many let's
do your next five moves so you pretty
much got the whole
you know what took place with the
processing of a title and then to cover
it the way we chose the cover is
you know i like red obviously vitamin is
red
and you know i i like the color red that
was chosen it's a different kind of a
red that's
on there and then i was originally going
to do it white with red on white
i mean white on red rather we said let's
switch it and let's make it so
red on white and we switched it and the
publisher actually originally made the
cover
and then eventually i just said let my
people make the cover and i had my
designer design this cover
so this cover is actually not made by
simon schutz and this cover is made by
us
we loved it and they said let's go with
this so we picked it wow that's
fantastic it's sometimes you know the
last five moves of a book
as i know from uh just the one one book
that i've written
but nevertheless it's something that's
essential because people judge it they
judge you by your cover they judge the
the title and people judge you and judge
you know an individual based on as you
say what's in your head what's in your
character what's in your heart
you focus on that a lot and
valuetainment on youtube and we'll
hopefully get to that later on uh i want
to come back to chess
i'm a scientist i'm a professor of
physics and astronomy at uc san diego
where i run the arthur c clarke center
for human imagination
and i'll be honest we got a lot of nerds
a lot of nerds listen to this show watch
this show on youtube
uh and we love chess and i i you know
part of it when i started reading it i
was like
is there going to be like 200 openings
you know from capablanca
to the king's indian i was kind of
stoked about that to be honest with you
but as i got deeper i realized this is
another kind of genre and
it's not even limited to uh to the title
you know business strategy i think that
actually is a little limiting if i could
tweak it
i would i would not limit it to that
because it's a psychology book it's
actually a self-improvement book
it's a book that to me you know they
talk about comps what what is this book
comparable to
to me it's kind of like this you know
strategic art of war
combined with rich dad poor dad combined
with
you know ray dalio and you know in
reading it i was like this kind of
reminds me of that and i looked at all
the endorsements on the back it's ray
dolly or kevin hart
uh you've got uh you've got robert
kiyosaki
got all these big big name people but
plus people like steve wozniak now most
people don't think of scientists like he
was
or engineers as outgoing you know the
old joke is how do you know an engineer
is outgoing
he looks at your shoes when he talks to
you
but in this case you know i i was
thinking about it because i used to
dabble in chess i'm not that great at
chess
there actually is a book called think
like a grandmaster and that's a phrase
used in the book and you've used in some
videos
it describes two different personalities
and i wonder which do you cleave more to
there's the depth versus the breath
there's the guy
who can think or girl who can think 50
moves ahead not not five not 15
50 moves ahead uh and and there may only
be 20 or 30
reasonable moves that a human being
could do and then there's you know it's
a really deep one then there's a broad
one who studied all the openings in that
book that i thought you wrote
you know with all these opening moves
and everything and then then the kind of
the closing takes care of itself
uh they separate via intellectual
horsepower the
the cpu the computer cycles that are
devoted
where do you see yourself are you the
deep guy the broad guy that the high
horsepower
intellect that just drills down like a
laser or are you
broad i i see behind you the shelf that
you talk about in the book
uh you're extremely well read uh i i
know that from
we have friends in common and they told
me that about you that you're just
thirsty so that to me speaks of breath
you just have one book that you've read
a hundred times you've got a thousand
books behind you
yeah so what are you are you a deep guy
are you a broad guy and you can't say
both
let me tell you that's a great question
you ask so you know
we would do the analysis of the four
personality types you know there's a lot
of different personality tests you can
take over the years you've probably
taken all of them you know
i'm an entj i mean yeah you know all
these guys put their uh what they are
the one that we would talk about was
stars so star is somebody who's very
structured
extremely organized they're systematized
everything to them is system system
system
then you have the technical which very
analytical
they they like data they break
everything down they want to know why
this took place
very very technical then you have the a
i'm going to go take over the world tell
me i can't do it i'm going to prove you
wrong
chippy competitive you know chip on her
shoulder then you have the r
tell me about yourself tell me about
your family tell me about your life tell
me who you are tell me how are things
you know very good with compassion very
good with building a relationship so for
me
for the longest time i thought i was an
arts
i'm not an s although if you ask anybody
here
i hire assets all the time if you the
best people that do very well with me
they're very organized because
everything in my life
needs to be organized even though i'm
not organized i have
you know people that help me get things
organized uh
eventually one day my wife and i were
sitting down
and uh people were asking yourself so
what is pat you know everybody i think
pat is an ar this patrick's at this pad
is that
she says i don't know i think pat's a t
and they said what do you mean she said
for for five and a half years when i
didn't date him when i watched him from
a distance
when we were in the same company
together pat always had a very strong
personality so i thought for a fact
he was an a and he was always there
where if i needed help and relationship
and
you know he was a good listener but
eventually i realized pat's a key
path is so analytical when it comes down
to everything what's the motive behind
this why did they do this what was that
what's this all about and at this point
of the game i will tell you i'm probably
very i would i would give it a little
bit of an edge of
a over t and then it's rs s is the least
but
it's probably going to be a and t very
close to each other when i was in
college and i took classes and
i aced my classes i would ace calculus
you know i would ace
anything that had to do with math
outside of geometry i wasn't too
interested in geometry i got to be in
geometry
but everything else there was a lot of
numbers a lot of data figuring problems
out
that interested me and i would fail
biology i don't have a lot of interest
in that so
for you to ask the depth versus the with
uh extremely curious my uncle was a
physicist i was always compared to my
uncle that was
extremely analytical so i would say
there's an element of that i'm always
curious to know if i was raised in a
family
where my parents weren't in the
situation they were at in say they were
able to
i was raised with a father and a mother
and i went to college i was always
cursed on what i would do i don't know
what i would do
would i go a degree in law or physicist
or physics or any of that stuff but it's
a great question you're asking i'd say
some technical and action combined so uh
what
that brings up and we talk about
personality tests and everything and i
can never remember if i'm a right brain
or a left
brain and i think that means i'm one of
those two brains i gotta be one of them
right
uh but uh but nevertheless i'm a
behaviorist i like to look at how people
behave
and sometimes the the owner's manual you
know when my wife and i had our first
kid
one day he was crying and i'm just like
uh get the owner's manual it's like
there is no owner's manual you know
you've got kids
and uh but i think you know there are
tools in this book both in the book and
the actual appendix of the book
and uh and elsewhere online at your next
five moves.com which we'll put links to
in the show notes
that are really about you know practical
tips to actually do stuff and as i was
thinking about this book
there's another book that kind of
reminded i thought it would remind me of
it because i'm also a private pilot in
my spare time which is not that much
and we always have checklists we always
have flight plans and a flight plan is
just your next five moves i mean you
can't actually know where this cloud is
gonna be
or you're gonna run out of uh you know
fuel over there some passengers gonna
have to
go to the bathroom you can only plan a
few moves ahead and you gotta be
flexible
and one of the things i liked about this
book compared to say atul gawande's
the checklist manifesto which has some
similarities is that there's actual
actionable ways that you can approach it
so i really salute that
uh process and you have this you know
personality audit
and we've gone over it but to impact 200
000 people i was kind of doing a little
simple math
how many other you know tools have had
such impact i mean
and actually you wrote this in in you
know you published this you know started
writing it probably finished it last
year earlier this year
it's probably even more so how do you
feel about that impact that you're
making for people like me who are kind
of
geeky nerds to actually sit down be
introspective
about what they're doing is that a value
to you
what is what is a value to me is when i
run into somebody
at the airport or the mall or somewhere
i'm out there and i'm at school and one
of the kids parents is a valetainer
and they come up and they say you know
the other day i was coming home at 10
o'clock at night a guy was chasing me
i'm like wait a minute what is this guy
chase man i'm pretty protect on my kids
and my wife's i come out i go up to the
guy says no no no no i'm just
i'm just somebody my wife and i watch
all your content indian engineer that
works at a local place
and he's 10 years older than me we had a
great conversation together
what what is rewarding is to hear people
that the philosophies and the content
shared on valuetainment help them
get clear on a decision they had to make
it's very very rewarding
what i what i don't do to myself is
i don't sit there and make myself think
that it's that big of a deal of what i'm
doing because it goes back to the stoic
stoic of
marcus irelias who would put a slave
behind him whispering in his ear you are
not as important as you think you are
because
sometimes i think when we uh allow too
much of the edification and the praise
and the flattery that comes your way you
are
almost stunned you know it stunts your
growth to the next level and i'm always
i'm curious about the unknown you know
because i already know what today feels
like i want to know what this feels like
what is
what is the possibility of raising kids
who one day they're able to do stuff
their dad couldn't do and
you know they're inspired to take this
mindset to the next level i'm always
curious about the unknown so in one way
very rewarding uh on the other side i
also don't put a lot of uh uh
i don't wake up and say oh my gosh i
need more of it
yeah and that's simply because i'm
curious about the next level
yeah hopefully we'll get a chance to
talk to what is your next level both in
terms of
you personally as patrick but also her
competition because you're in a very
heated field you're in a very
competitive um
market unlike you know me there's
there's more you know people
playing starting lineup in the nba than
practicing experimental cosmologists who
are studying the origin of the universe
uh so but that can be also challenging
because if you're in a smaller pond
you know sometimes it's the the
competition can be pretty darn fierce as
well
especially in academia nowadays but i
want to talk to you about possible
competitors
and some of the stuff that i see you
know i'm sure he's not watching this but
you know people like gary vee
you know it's like there's so much of
these types of people ramit seti and
other people like
really promoting this idea of hustle and
and finding your your niche and just
how they'll teach you to be rich rich
dad even rich dad poor dad you know some
think it's a little bit on this
on the scammy side just to be honest
with you um and sometimes they're all in
conflict like there's
there's a lot of psychology in this book
and what i like about it is you're just
like here's what you do when somebody
ticks you off
take responsibility state specifically
what you did channel your frustration
into getting better so it's a
self-improvement book
masquerading as a business book but what
do you say to people
um like some of the skeptics who who
like feel about gary vee
or somebody like that that they are
really just kind of promoting their own
book they're really like to use the
insurance or whatever like they're
selling their own stuff
and and they actually are depending on
people to fail
it seems like you are engaged with
people succeeding not failing like
weight watchers
they only make business because people
like me go back and recidivism is high
how do you how do you like keep
integrity and such
in such an environment you know i read a
quote
a long time ago by is is it richard
branson the guy from virgin i think it's
richard branson
he said uh uh he said
teach your guys your employees
everything
that you know so they can go away leave
you and compete against you
but treat them so well that they don't
want to okay
it's a fascinating message to be given
right where it's important listen i'm
gonna share everything
i do with you guys i select one of the
things i have a reputation for if you
work with me
i always like to do meetings and another
person sit next to me because i want you
to learn how i negotiate i want you to
learn
how to put out a fire i want you to know
and see
well that one time pat got heated but he
went from heated to this point and how
was he able to bring it down and why did
he get heated and
but he's done this seven different times
and it's always worked out well and what
happened there
how is it that two personalities get
heated and then they end up becoming
friends and do business together
for a long time and you know he realizes
what area he has to say that was my bad
will fix it and the other you know puts
the pressure on the other person
because because it's an element of
shadowing and learning from somebody
else on what to do and what not to do
right that that's that's a part of
uh doing that but but going back to
these guys and what they're doing
look my my ideas i was one time
interviewed with i think
cardone and cardone one time said
you know i was telling them the fact
that communism is not a good idea he
says well communism is good if you're
the communist in charge
and i said i have no desire for power
because power comes easy
i don't care about that i'm driven by
freedom i left iran to come here because
i wanted freedom so as far as
some of these other guys what they're
doing um i think time will tell us too
early to tell who's who and what they're
doing
you got 10 more years 20 more years to
really tell
what people's outcomes were some
people's outcomes you're not going to
know some of them you're just not going
to get revealed
for a very long time like i bet you at
45 years old trump probably knew he's
possibly going to be running one day and
he never really told anybody outside of
the people on the inner circle
and he thought about it what if i run
one day i promise you that uh
and obama maybe at one point knew hey
you know one day i wouldn't mind making
a run out and see what i can do you know
a must
one day probably said i'm gonna go out
there and do something and compete
against nasa but
how do you say that to a friend and say
i'm gonna beat nasa one day nasa's gonna
say
you know for us to go to space stay
there for two weeks and come back and
have safe landings it's gonna take
12 years and 26 billion dollars this is
a committee led by obama-led committee
that said it's going to take 12 years 26
billion
and here's a elon musk that's an
entrepreneur comes and says i'm gonna do
it in six years with less than a billion
dollars i mean
you have to know you don't know what
everybody else is thinking and what all
their motives and visions are
but when you listen to everybody today
what their messaging is
some people are just driven by money and
fame and success
you know some people are simply looking
for that and there's nothing wrong with
that some people just want more
and more and more of success and credit
and all that other stuff
and some are not some vision is much
bigger than that and unfortunately
i said this to a couple of my friends
the other day we're sitting out i run a
mentoring call on tuesdays
with the executives of my company i said
how do you know who's a visionary
so i said i got a question for all of
you can you tell me the difference
between a visionary and a bullshitter
what is the difference because they both
talk a big game they're both sales
right there salesman my wife told me she
said you know
you and my ex have one thing in common
and one thing that was very different i
said what is it
she said you know both of you were very
good at
talking dirty about what you're gonna do
big in your life one day
i said what's the difference you
actually did it
so so you don't know the difference
between somebody that's like one day
we're gonna go out there and one day
we're gonna go out there
you don't know if this guy's telling the
truth or not the only way you're gonna
know it's gonna take a decade or two so
i think it's still very early in the
game i think we'll have to revisit this
when we're in our mid 50s or early 60s
to see
what everybody's really up to and at
that point of the game it's going to get
very clear by the way here's one thing
we have to realize that
too often we forget that there's been
many people who were celebrities at one
point that were forgotten about
we're very quick to forget that i mean
just because somebody's a star today we
think this person is going to be around
forever it's
very very hard the reason why ray
charles and sting
have so much respect is because they had
a number one hit in four different
decades it is very very
difficult to stay relevant for a long
time so i think it's too early but we'll
find out what happens in the next few
decades
so i want to ask you because it's not so
often i get to speak with someone so
knowledgeable about insurance
and i i want you to convince me that i'm
wrong i think insurance is a scam
basically people are betting in the
insurance company
that i'm going to live and i'm betting
i'm going to die uh or vice versa
and i'm just like i look at it like i
can see you were just out in vegas as i
understand from the podcast
and it was kind of dead out there but
you look at these casinos and they have
no windows in them and they're palaces
and it's like
the maximum edge you can possibly get in
any game besides poker
is like 1.5 that the house has 1.5
percent edge and with that edge they can
make millions and million billions of
dollars in some at least before now
how is insurance different from that i
mean they got to be making
you know making making serious money
somehow and if that's by betting that
you're gonna you know
that you're you're betting you're gonna
die and so you wanna protect against
that are most insurance policies
basically scams or am i just
totally full of it so i'm going to ask
the question different for from you let
me ask you
when does the insurance company make
more money if you keep the policy or
cancel the policy
oh you want to they want you to keep it
right no the other way around
oh they get terminations and stuff like
that i have insurance from the governor
that you love so much gavin and gavin
newsom so i i
love you so much yeah you're right but
you know i will tell you this
think about it yeah the insurance
company the only way you get even with a
life insurance company is if you keep
your policy
if you keep your policy you win they
lose i'll give you a
quick example so think about it the
insurance policy is hoping
every time there's a crisis like this
that like right now coronavirus took
place right guess who made money
all the insurance companies made money
why let me explain to you why life
insurance companies made money
what do you think is one of the first
things people cancel when a crisis takes
place
cancel their insurance they cancel the
life insurance policy now watch this
i say i've had a term insurance policy
with metlife and i've had it for 12
years
and i've been paying 80 a month it's a
million dollar policy okay
crisis takes place i cancelled my
insurance policy i was paying
dollars a month right eighty dollars a
month over twelve years is
how much money it's around twelve
thousand dollars but that twelve
thousand dollars now kept by who
the insurance company if i not wanted to
start an insurance policy would it be
eighty dollars a month
no it'd be higher because i'm 12 years
older and i'm probably heavier i
probably had a couple surgeries
so my 80 a month for a million dollars
is now 400
a month so if you wanted to buy a policy
now you're paying
five times more than you were paying
before so insurance companies make money
because they know most
people don't keep their insurance
policies and once you cancel your
insurance policy and it lapses
that's all profits going to the
insurance company so the best way to get
even with life insurance companies
is buy it and don't cancel they hate
that
if you buy it and don't ever cancel it
they eventually have to pay out the math
to you the money to you
and what about you know some bypassing
you know what you
what you guys do and go directly like
can i get a better policy if i just
better deal with me as brian keating i
go to the insurance
why do i need patrick why do i need the
company
yeah so so the way matt the way math
works on life insurance is
there is not a wholesale retail meaning
if you buy it from me or you buy it
directly from aig or you buy it from
another agent that works for me it's the
same exact rate there is no
you know if i buy this uh from directly
wholesale it's going to cost you four
dollars but if you buy it from amazon
it's 14
but if you buy it from me at a swap meet
is 22 that's not how insurance works
whatever the insurance pot you can go to
a website called term for sale
and it just tells you everybody's price
for their life insurance policy so
you don't even need to have an agent you
just go find out what is the cheapest
term insurance policy for your agent how
much you want
and that's the price no matter who you
buy from direct from a website from an
individual so there is no wholesale
retail when it comes down to life
insurance pricing
i got it okay uh the next next topic i
want to turn to
uh really comes through uh in your in
the acknowledgment section at the end of
the book uh
which is easily devoured and um you
obviously thank your wife your co-author
etc but the the most kind of touching
thing to me
was this following sentence um how
valuetainers uh have impacted you
so i wouldn't be writing this book you
say or creating new content if it
weren't for the millions of valuetainers
and entrepreneurs
who follow the content on a monthly
basis i'm grateful to you
you energize me in ways that words can't
describe first of all is your wife
pissed off that you acknowledge the
valuetainers almost as much as you did
to her
probably the most easy going person
you'll meet in your life so i go to the
valuetainment
youtube channel i click on about and it
says an entrepreneur channel created by
serial entrepreneur
patrick david valuetainment is referred
to as the best channel for entrepreneurs
with weekly how to's motivation
interviews with unique individuals
you've done such an amazing job with the
channel
it gave me an idea you reputedly i
talked to one of your high school
guidance counselors
you had a 1.8 gpa you didn't go to
college you went to the army thank you
so much
for doing that us army um and uh
and and you've become this huge success
my question for you is
if you if you were not going to go to
college but you're going to create
bet david university what would you
offer what would you teach the students
there that they
would need to know and could uniquely
learn from you let me tell you would be
all human nature it would be all
debate my entire education so you got to
realize i go on four different 20-year
terms right first 20 years was
don't make a big mistake second 20 years
is go find one industry stick to it and
make your money like real money so you
can
take that money in the next one combine
your your crusade your cause your
passion
and turn it into a business which is the
next 20 years and the last 20 years is a
formal contribution given back
politics education nonprofit etc etc if
i were to start a university one day
let's call it
david university my university would be
very very different here's how my
university would be if we're teaching
if we're teaching economics you would
have two professors or maybe three
professors you would have a socialist a
communist and a capitalist
and you get to watch them debate
non-stop that's how i would teach
if you want to have a you know of course
you're taking on marriage and
relationship you would have somebody
that's single
never got married you'd have somebody
that's divorced happily divorced
and you got somebody that's happily
married they're each gonna sell you why
you
ought to consider getting married why
you ought to consider you know marriage
is tough to be
or i'm just happy staying single if i'm
teaching you negotiation skills you
would get the people that are
you know hostage negotiators you would
get people that went to prison and are
drug dealers
you get the people that worked in the
streets you get the people that worked
in the business world that did the
biggest deals when it comes to
negotiation
you will learn that you learn human
nature you have people sitting down on
stage
and i would say can you read that
person's body language how do they feel
right now do they trust you do they not
trust you
what's that giving you what is this
giving you how do you read this person's
tale how do you read that person's tale
it would be a very different kind of a
human nature university to be going to
and then of course we would have the
courses to teach but it wouldn't be
about oh i got a four-year degree from
bed david university
right it would be more closer to an
academy
a military toughness mental emotional
toughness type of an academy when you
come out of there being the future
governor president ceos
you know disrupters of the world that
would be more the mindset than more let
me go take a
you know philosophy do you feel like
augmented reality and artificial
intelligence has a role to actually play
in that where you could war game with
genghis khan you could put you know
robert e lee over there you could do
sort of the battles and the skirmishes
and and karl marx you know and and and
you know adam smith put them together
could could you see that
so have you spoken to anybody that knows
me very well that i wrote a fiction book
do you know what's in the fiction book
no i don't i'm sorry no i didn't do my
homework
don't give me a nap please no one knows
that i thought maybe you have gone that
far
because so i have a fiction book that i
wrote that's 95 000 words that i will
not launch until i leave php because
it kind of reveals how i view the world
wow and
what i would listen it's it's it's a
little bit political it's a little bit
controversial people are going to say
this guy's a little weird
on how we've used things but one of the
things is studying uh uh you know i have
a painting on the wall right there
yeah yeah tell me that show me that
characters yeah you know i have a
painting on the wall there and i can
sorry pat can you go back to that
because i i was talking over it
yeah it's it's it's called dead mentors
so you'll see
lincoln there you'll see jfk it's
opposing personalities by the way
einstein who's a math genius but he
believed in socialism milton friedman
who's a math genius but he's a
capitalist
mlk who took his approach in a different
way and tupac took the
approach a little more controversial and
i have senna who's
fierce competitor then he had the shaw
in the middle and they're debating two
books
communist manifesto and atlas shrug in
the middle and then you got marcus
aurelius and he got aristotle
and a bunch of hidden stuff and it's a
vault they're in a bank vault having
strong debates together so for me
why waste all these dead people that did
incredible things in their lives
mistakes good things bad things
why not study them the universe what i
talk about in the fiction book it's kind
of a combination of hunger games
divergent meets i am legend all combined
together that's kind of what that book
is about but
two three years from now to be out but
some of the stuff you talked about is
actually in that book i wrote it like
seven years ago
oh i'd love to i'd love to read that
help out whatever way i can that's uh
really fascinating i feel like you know
i'm a pretty smart guy i'm a good
professor
but you know am i better than galileo
you know you want to sit down with
galileo to learn about that
uh to learn about you know uh motion or
einstein learn about relativity
obviously you do and so um you know we
can aspire and i think having that you
mentioned that painting in the book it's
great to see it in
in person so to speak i want to move now
to a couple of uh you know sort of rapid
fire
questions and then i want to uh conclude
with some questions i ask
all my guests if you if you still have a
little bit of time um
first question is given all the
personalities you've interacted with i
see you as this kind of like
molecule that's literally been on you
know all these different continents
except antarctica that might be the only
place i've been that you haven't been
but never i don't know maybe you've been
there uh we could do a valuetainment
summit there but um i want to ask you of
all the personality types you meet
which is kind of the worst thing you
look for in avoiding a person
and what are kind of the best things
that you look for in in
working with someone an employee
obviously integrity
is different in a spouse but let me just
say in an employee employer dynamic
what are some of the things you you
avoid like the plague
sorry to bring that up or and things
that you gravitate towards like a
magnetic field
so it depends on what the position is
and what you're doing for example i'll
break it down for you if i'm dealing
with a sales
person uh or somebody is in sales that's
working 10.99
i look for somebody that played sports i
look for somebody that's got a chip i
look for somebody that uh
you know had a massive public
humiliation of a loss a breakup
i looked for somebody that had major
challenges that took place with them
uh i look for that if i'm dealing with
uh sales and so because they have to be
competitive you got to be willing to do
the work
60 80 hours a week if i'm dealing with
somebody that's more operations
and customer service i'm looking for
somebody that's
you know maybe a certain spiritual
foundation
faith but we're a little bit more easy
going to deal with customers and
you know like one of the folks i have
working here alexis she's i've never met
anybody that's that good with people
i've never met anybody that's that good
with people and she she's able to
address
issues in a way that others cannot she
came from sales but she wasn't good in
sales but she's very good in dealing
with people
so the same person didn't do well in
sales but she does very well when it
comes down to
addressing issues then if i'm dealing
with somebody that's uh finances
and it's economics i almost need
somebody that's a little bit of a loner
uh uh you know i need somebody that's uh
not doesn't talk too much that
maybe is not very personable maybe is a
little bit private
uh doesn't uh want a lot of bragging
rights you know it just kind of wants to
do the job and
you know get respected for it once
there's an exit or
a victory that's what i look for when it
comes when it comes on to somebody with
money finance when i'm dealing with
operations i'm dealing with somebody
who is extremely analytical yet
step-by-step
process and a little bit annoying a
little bit quirky a little bit like
uh uh can get under your skin a little
bit you know like
you're semi annoying obnoxious but you
trust it because they just have a method
of
you know back to back to back to back to
back they can do the same thing over and
over again so again
going back to answering your question
for you it all depends
on position and department but yes
everybody has a little bit of a quirk
that helps
in that department great i want to turn
towards i'll i'll
have a one more rapid fire question but
before i get there i want to talk about
the youtube channel
uh because i have about the square root
of the number of the subscribers that
you do
uh which is not that many uh you know
from mathematics uh but
uh nevertheless i want to ask you how
did you build it uh what was kind of the
inspiration for doing it and
and obviously i'd like to know how can
somebody like me starting off develop it
grow an audience
you know think about how do you think
about monetization et cetera and i don't
really focus so much on that but
growing the youtube channel what it's
done for you what it's done against you
you know because it's made you the
superstar in a certain sense and
i want to talk about fame and at the
very end of this but first of all
how did you do it what's uh what are
what are some tips or
five moves that we can apply out there
and and that are aspiring
so first of all let me ask you this how
many people have you interviewed
yourself how many people have you
interviewed
uh 68 68. okay i've been interviewed by
a lot of people
your top three best ever that's ever
interviewed and i'm not
well you can't well you can't see me say
this to other people so if you go watch
other people that have interviewed me
i've never said this to anybody so i'm
saying this to you
because you're you're gentle you make me
trust you to open up to you and talk to
and it's almost like it's just you and i
even though there's audience that's
watching us
the idea of somebody that can interview
has to make me feel
uh very comfortable that i'm speaking to
them you can do that you
are able to do proper research you ask
me questions other people are not asking
so you're not the conventional there's a
mercy
yeah i mean embarrassing mercy mercy yes
you are welcome
any sufficiently advanced technology is
indistinguishable from magic
if you enjoyed this episode of into the
impossible please subscribe
comment share rate and review for a
chance to win a free copy of our most
recent guest's newest book
send a screenshot of your review to info
imagine.ucsd.edu
we appreciate hearing from you and are
always open to your suggestions for
future episodes
for more information go to
imagination.ucsd.edu
find us on twitter at imagineucsd
watch us on youtube listen on itunes
into the impossible is a production of
the arthur c clarke center for human
imagination
in the division of physical sciences at
the university of california
san diego eric very director
brian keating co-director patrick
coleman associate director
produced by stuart valco